alright JD it's time to meet your fourth
woman can you tell us a little bit about
her this is an she's 26 she's five six
she's brunette with brains she's from
the Big D Dallas Texas she went to
Stanford she's currently at Columbia
medical school thinking gynecology and
she's a guitar hero freak and her
favorite movie is the Godfather Wow we
don't need to do it that's fine he's
like Guitar Hero let's go all right all
right
start the clock let these two mean it's
going no no I think it's ginger ale but
yeah take a sip I've never had ginger
ale so I'm afraid to drink it how long
have you been working here like seven
years okay yeah and with you you study
for you study ecology I know I want to
go into your gynecology college I guess
I take your really how long have you
gone to middle school I just finished my
first year yeah I'm doing a research
right now in this summer oh yeah
so do you get nervous around celebrities
on the show I guess celebrities I get
around anyone anyone I don't know yeah
as you can tell I can't really talk
right now you like The Godfather any of
it how many times have you seen it
Oh guys you know um maybe like 10 15
times Wow I don't know have you seen oh
yeah a few times few times okay uh and
how many have any Guitar Hero's have you
played guitar huh
um I don't know I you know I kind of
switched over to rock band though so
it's been a while since I've actually
played guitar here but I got pretty good
I always on like I was on expert for a
little while oh Jesus Christ I can't
even do but I like the drums now and
rock man you know what I played the
drums at the John Hines house it's a
friend of Mines I can do all right your
two minutes are up I have never heard a
date like that beautiful girl very nice
to meet you and good luck with your
medical thank you I hope we'll be seeing
you more at our parties and things when
ad begins marrying you that's right
begins of the marital process Wow I
thought chemistry with the last two
girls I think 4jd